all right for people who are joining
this
live stream we are talking about
language design
around a rape processing for language
so we we have uh we had met about a
month ago
and had a bunch of i thought pretty good
ideas
um that centered around
this idea of uh
i i thought we had a better name for
this that i had suggested after that
meeting
um for this thing that was maybe it's
threaded
this thing that is an
externally visible wrapper that
causes um functions
to thread themselves in different ways
did that make sense to everybody
uh yes we know we're talking about that
so to what was what was the final name
that we
oh i see threaded was the name that we
were that you were suggesting here
okay so so this is so we have two
different kinds of approaches
one kind of approach is from the outside
that is you've got a collection of
arrays
and you've got a function and you want
to tell the function
the arrays themselves do not identify
what they want to have happen
but you are telling it from the outside
i want to apply this function to this
sequence of elements in the sequence of
arrays is that correct
correct yes so this is the idea put
forward in this notebook
the external approach and
at the end there is a connection to
threaded
okay okay so but wait a second so the
thing we're talking about is
the first step is you've got certain
this is very much like tensor analysis
with tensor contractions and so on
you've got a collection of tensors
arrays whatever
and you have a function and you want
that function to take
uh you know axis seven of array one
and and combine it with axis 4 of array
2
and produce a a combined array that has
been
uh kind of knitted together along those
axis
is that correct yes correct
so what we were discussing is something
like if i have a list of vectors and i
want to add another vector
it will be uh the second level
of the first array the first level of
the second right but this is from the
outside as opposed to
the threaded mechanism where what you
would do is you would say
um you know threaded of the vector you
want to add in
plus the list of vectors and then the
threaded thing would automatically know
that it's going to put itself into that
collection of vectors
right right so i think at the very end i
have a value
which does the connection we can perhaps
go there and see
we will explain uh yeah so
exactly these exactly so you see how
i need to do i need to run a bunch of
other things here i need to make a bunch
of other definitions don't i
um i think i think the section called
code probably is everything you have to
to run
okay this still seems compatible deep
dimensions q doesn't seem to be defined
it's just in next line oh okay
okay all right
so what are we looking at here we're
looking at yes so i think
let us explore this this value in in the
previous line
so we have if we have an arbitrary
function f
with a raise on the left some threaded
in the middle and some other arrays on
the right
then what what i'm suggesting is that we
could have an extension of map thread
which takes negative levels
and what this is doing is just saying oh
thread the arrays at the deepest levels
it's like you have arrays of vectors he
will do the threadings on the vectors
irrespectively of the depth of the
arrays themselves
right right yeah the only check is that
all these vectors need to have the same
length of course
but so what this is doing is it's the
opposite default
a listable function for us right now
threads by default at the highest level
so for example let's
to do the example here the current
a current listable function like plus
will take
um you know if i say a b
plus c d we all know what that does
but if i now say x y
s t plus c d
that's what it does right as opposed to
what we wanted to do with threaded which
is if i said plus
threaded cd then what i would want this
to produce
is x plus let's see what do i want this
to produce
actually in this particular case it's
doing the same thing isn't it
or am i confused no no i i'm confused
sorry
you want to say x plus c y plus d
s plus c t plus d correct
right and you can do that if you replace
actual plus with lowercase plus
because stability breaks
listability is applied before up values
okay all right that's the example on the
left
okay wait a minute i've got a problem
here hold on
um something is wrong with my
file system uh could somebody
oh this is bad this my file system is
just hanging completely
great could somebody contact roger yeah
i'll let him know
i that this this session is now frozen
because my file system is frozen
well we can talk but nothing else so
somebody else will have to share but
um yeah
okay so so i can't scroll this notebook
but what you're saying is in this case
here
what you're doing is you've you've
implemented threaded
but we can't actually implement threaded
because of the order of listability
correct right attributes are applied
before
up values so it would thread before
so i mean this there's an implementation
issue here about dealing with this but
what we're trying to understand is the
concept right
so right and uh well i mean do you have
any examples with more than one threaded
in them because
that is sort of what one of i mean i
think when you have more than two arrays
it's potentially ambiguous as is but
certainly
yeah right exactly so listability
already has that ambiguity and we've
lived with it for a third of a century
um with limited problems but i agree if
you put two threadeds in there what's it
going to do
it's going to execute them in order one
by one
okay and so that will decide what
happens
as in from left to right
i guess so um hey roger i assume you
logged into this machine and can you
tell me what's going on with the file
system
please um well i
just got notifications i'm not exactly
sure what's okay i'm trying to save
something out from will from desktop
and it's just spinning right in other
words it's trying to access the the
default
okay all right onward so go ahead
what were you saying about multiple
threaded stuff
yes we were discussing the order in
which this would happen and i guess it's
left to right
but it's decided by the evaluator
okay i i think that's as reasonable as
it could be i mean if you just say
threaded plus threaded
presumably that that's pretty
straightforward but if you say
thing plus threaded plus thing plus
threaded
um i mean for example
if there are different default sizes if
one of them is size three
if you're threading size three vectors
in one threaded and size two vectors in
the other threaded
will it go to the level that last
matches
that particular size do you understand
what i'm saying
yes so what i implemented here i
wouldn't do that it this
starts by saying are all the arrays at
the deepest level compatible
and only act if that's true is it
obviously wrong to say
you know go to the level at which it's
compatible with the threaded
i mean that's what people would want
most of the time
but i find it a bit unpredictable it's
the sort of thing which you are using
two by three matrices and
doesn't work and then you use two by two
and that's a different thing
i understand that's not super desirable
um
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna kill this but i
this is not going to work here
i'm giving up on roger fixing this so
i'm just killing it
oh wow that's exciting refuses to die
that sounds like the network file system
issue right
it's what i think it is that's why i
asked roger to look at it but apparently
he's not producing nothing so
yeah this isn't even dying even even
though i'm telling it to
um even though i did force quit and even
though the application is no longer says
it's running
well try opening it again
maybe we'll have ghost windows left over
i've never seen that before i thought
the application owned the windows
well you could also open one of your
other it looks like six or seven
uh mathematicals
wow this is a pretty interesting
operating system problem
usually when i've uh done when i've seen
this i've had to
either you know restart completely or at
least go to find her
and you know restart the finder because
there's something in the
uh there should you know
there's something stuck that needs to be
unstuck
why don't you try opening a different
mathematica well i'm gonna try and kill
the finder
except i can't even figure out how to do
that it's command option escape
okay i killed the file that was kind of
oh look
but command option escapes still thinks
there's a wall from desktop running
even though we'll try force quitting it
from there
i am oh wow look at that it all
disappeared
well let's try it again i think it's
going to fail again
jose do you have this notebook really
handy maybe it would be
better if we share if you share for now
and
again yeah
yeah okay go ahead then sure
okay you see my notebook
okay yes so
i evaluated these same things so these
are the examples we were looking at
and yeah right so we see
x plus y i mean a plus x b plus y right
so we've
replicated the x y across all the levels
exactly so this is a deeper level uh a
deeper case in which we have an array
which is
two by two by two and with thread also
at the deepest level
and um so these are three there are
three arrays so here we have the vector
here we have a two by two
and here we have a three a two by two by
two
so we are threading at the dimension the
deepest dimension is two in all cases
now there is no we can thread also
several levels so for example here we
are threading
an array it's like map thread can can
thread up
level two so we can also thread here
it's like the
the yeah the deepest level so actually
sorry just a quick question
um i thought there was also
like last time i talked about didn't we
have a second argument for threaded if
you wanted to thread it at different
levels yes
we did um
yes that yes that's not implemented here
so i mean for example when we when we
say here
when we say map thread level two it's
threading the first two levels not just
level two
the the same thing could be done here
saying
map thread minus two it would thread the
two deepest levels
not just level minus two but i i think
it can also be done
right so right the implementation we
have here is
doing it at the deepest level so we
don't really
have a design yet i think or or an
obvious implementation for the
at arbitrary levels i mean this is a
pretty quick mock-up i'm not saying
it would be super hard i just don't
think we've necessarily thought that
through
right i mean i think last time we had
some implementation like i think i
wrote something quickly that was like
using just map and you
but but i think it's it's it's probably
equivalent to this
right so i think the the the key idea is
rather than
counting from the top is counting from
the bottom
of the array structure and so and a nice
example
which is where the the the
uh the ideas come from is is quantity
array quantity array is doing this
deep threading already and so this is an
example of replicating quantity array
but using thread
so for example if we have this array of
magnitudes of a two
by three by two array and we have a pair
of units
we are going to thread this pair of
units with this
level and so what would just do
is to put thread here
and this automatically because it
threads at the deepest level of max
does that which is equivalent so this is
this is the proposed extension
which would be threading these two
arrays at the deepest level
and so if we do quantity array of max
comma units like like this one
and normalize we get exactly the same
result
right so this is an application of a
case in which we are not doing
simply plus it's just some other
function
right which is actually very neat i mean
it basically
it gets rid of a whole class of i mean
what it seems like it basically does it
lets you use the stability on functions
that aren't listable
or or with a different listability
because quantity is listable but
i mean at least double in the first
argument not only right right so like
let's see right let's see one both make
functions listable that weren't and it
also lets you control
what ways they're listable and how the
listability is is matching up and so on
so it's very neat
all right
okay um so i'm still debugging my
computer but can you repeat that
yeah so we were discussing this this
example of which is a
which is an example different from using
plus which is the example we have always
been using
so we have a magnitude an array of two
by three by two
and a pair of units and we want to
thread this pair of units with this
level with the third level
so we just do this right so let's
evaluate it again
so we just do this and so the this is
the
the threaded form this would be the oh i
see that's very nice
yeah extension this is something that
map thread cannot do yet
threading at the level -1 and then what
i wanted to show is that this is exactly
what
quantity array is doing inside it's
storing the max and the units separate
and when it normalizes it threats
and it gets the same result it threats
at the deepest level very nice
okay so look it seems to me that
threaded is a winner so let's go back
up to your map thread discussion um
yes so so this this discussion here is a
discussion of the extension of the
function
so this is a an implementation so this
is a this is first a way of showing that
what map thread does can be done with
this extension
uh this general function to perform
threadings
and so for example threading three
levels of these arrays and and these
numbers represent their dimensions
so they are these three is threading
through levels one two and three
which must agree on dimensions two three
and four so this is represented in this
case by saying
thread the the first and the first the
second and the second the third and the
third
and then this is the the typical f and g
discussion
the f function the the first argument of
author
and then this is the g discussion like
the the contracting function there
like we use foreign exactly this is
exactly like inner
f and g so wait a minute so what does
inner does inner not take level specs
uh only for the first array yes this is
a symmetry here so inner we can do
f of um a
b c d and then
one one two
three four and so by default let's put a
d
here but if we do that
which is contracting this the second
level of the first with the first of the
second
and we can control the level of the
first
and so sorry sorry yeah
so these will do exactly a slightly
different thing so
so in this case it's contracting the
second level of this
with the first level of this and here
it's contracting the
first level of this with the first level
of this so we can
control the level the first level of
this but not the level of this one
that would be i know perhaps a nice
extension right so right now it only
accepts integers and that
fourth or fifth argument is that true
yeah i could probably accept a list of
integers to specify what to do in
different
for different but it's still inner is
not going to work because it's a binary
operator basically
right yeah
yeah so so this this object which is now
also added to the ball from functional
repo
takes the general function f as in outer
and list of arrays as in map thread
or or fl in flattened form as an outer
then this is the specification of the
contractions you want
so you the each of these vectors needs
to have the same length of this
and you say the level of the array you
want and if you don't want that array to
participate in the
contraction you put a zero zero
a zero yes it's it's a random thing but
it's a specification of i don't want
that array to be
participating what would be the natural
thing you want it to participate as a
whole lump
so you want that array to be treated
like it is a single atomic thing
is that correct by not participating in
the threading operation
in other words if you make that array if
the array wasn't list if it was
something different
well no okay here everything needs to be
a
a race no i understand that but i'm
saying what does it mean to not
participate
doesn't it mean that you're treating
that array as atomic for purposes of
these operations
yeah so let's see if i can well not
really right because
you're it doesn't participate at all as
opposed to
being a lump but what is it
but it gets fed in as f of something
doesn't it
what what actually happens to that array
so let's try to see some example one two
um let me join here
and and a b
and now so the simplest case would be i
want a contraction of the first level
and the first level
and right so this is doing this
so now if i say do not have
the first array participating
then it's doing this so hold on hold on
hold on what's that doing
what does that mean so that what did
that just do
and why are there double list packets
for that third argument
right so we started with okay so let's
put a g
here so that's going to be clear
so we started with a list analyst
so the outer form would be
a matrix and so we are now
one of the levels of that matrix is
being
contracted with g so
if if we do this we just have that
it's it's the full array this is outer
so you can imagine that this operation
is first you do the outer
and then you do the contractions marked
here
and there can be even no contraction
whatsoever which is this case
right so this is outer half
so you're saying you can have a list of
contraction pairs
yes yes i could i mean if if this was a
matrix and a matrix i could contract
one and another one but then you could
have the reason there's an outer list
bracket
is because i mean and probably there's
an aligned syntax where you don't have
the outer list bracket if there's only a
single pair
right if there's only a single pair you
shouldn't need the outer list bracket
do you mean like that yes yeah that
i i'm not sure it works but it should
yeah it works okay fine fine okay but
fine but so so
the the point is that that is it is like
the
you know for tensors it's like the
summation convention you're making a
list
of the pairs that you're going to knit
together correct
right exactly yes except it can be more
than pairs it can be triples and things
as well right
if you if you had three lists at the
beginning there
you could have f of three arguments
exactly so
i can do a contraction of three here uh
right and all of them are
so can you copy that input and change
one of those ones to
a zero yeah let me see what that looks
like
okay what on earth happened here
so this array is not being uh
uh contracted so the the abs nature of
the thing
is preserved so you see the list with an
a
a and then bb is preserved
so we can preserve now the inner one
and now it's a that is repeated
so they see so what it means is i don't
think zero is the right thing i think it
should be none or something like that
probably what should it naturally be it
what does that what is that index that
index
right so basically it's an index that
remains uncontracted
right so the the 101 means you have an
aba somewhere in your indices right
yeah i think i'm using this because this
internal is a packed array
okay okay but but but conceptually what
should it be
that is specifying the the level number
at which the contraction is happening so
none would be the correct way to say
there isn't a level number don't
contract this
if i'm not mistaken yeah
i think so okay all right fine
okay so so let's so i mean this looks
good what what
what's the problem here this looks like
a good thing
uh and i mean no no nothing i'm just
explaining
my my construction of math threat is
based on this so i'm just explaining why
this
how this function works right i mean the
the i think the main
problem is is is implementational right
i mean this is sort of
fascinating yeah right this is a
top-level naive implementation which is
perfectly
fine right but so long as we once we
know that we really want it then we can
worry about
about more internal implementations
right
could we compare it to net map thread
operator
i think you need to down arrow into it
okay
so ignore the associations that's just
because
um net layers have to
have inputs all named so the
associations there would be replaced
with
a list n1n2 etc
okay so is is your belief that this does
something very similar to jose's map
thread or is it
this is something that does something
very different i i don't know
okay can we look at details on options
boy um the relevant note is actually
right next to the cursor
so it says it maps the network at level
that's the maximum of those things by
replicating those inputs that
have less than that
right so replication is a is a closely
related operation here and i think i
have to comment here
because there is this other function
generalizing map thread in that
directions too
the idea of replication so this is not
looking at negative threading
but it's looking at replication so a
couple of questions here
in the case of the generalized map
thread what would it do on associations
i mean map thread itself should work on
associations and currently doesn't
is it obvious what it should do i mean i
think it's very obvious what it should
do
so it should thread the corresponding
keys is that correct
if you have two associations and you say
map thread
well no so they're actually two they're
two ways in which associations can be
involved
one is at the top level so that list of
arrays could also be an association of
arrays
i don't i'm not sure i agree with that
but the other one is a list of
associations which i think is more
useful
right an association of lists is one
thing
and in that case the natural thing to do
would be
to say when in the in the threading
specification
to make the threading specification be
an association so it can refer to
different um
you know to the disposition no i'm sorry
every sub-list
in the threading specification becomes
an association in that case
am i making sense
right i mean what could i mean what
might make sense here and i'm not quite
sure
i you know this is thing you know i
haven't thought all right
right that you know you could have a
pound one sort of function
right a pound a and pound b sort of
function right that
yes you could yes that's that is the
natural
meaning right when we've talked about
sort of
generalizing map thread to have an
allowed heads option
then we've uh
right the outer list is always a list
and then it's just the inner heads that
need to
right but when there's a generalized map
thread with its threading specification
one could have been referring to
different arrays
by their keys rather than by their
positions
that again somewhat uncontroversial yeah
yeah
those keys wouldn't play any other role
actually right they're just
they're just referring to they're just a
way of essentially locally naming those
tensors
yeah okay but so did this work
this does work already yeah i didn't
know okay
all right fine so then then if that
function f
could you try the hash hash a
in the no no what are you doing what are
you doing don't know
i was trying to to see whether it
requires order
it does okay all right okay so now
in there put in um in the f
can we make that f be hash
um hey yeah okay
yeah you could just do hash a plus b but
yeah fine
try it try it try it no no f of a hash a
doesn't matter hash a hash yeah b comma
hash a just so we see it do something
nontrivial
hash be f b comma hash a okay
okay ampersand obviously i'm sorry
okay it's fed the naked arguments so
it's basically
well i'm not you know basically doing
the value what it does
well in this case that this is correct
you you'd want it you'd only want it to
do this if there's an association on the
outside lists on the inside wouldn't you
uh why isn't that being fed in the final
knitting
could you evaluate the line before
please
um that one there okay
so because look the first one is
combining the two a's and the second
one's combining
two b's so of course there shouldn't be
a hash and hash b but only if you have
the association on the outside
you are right you're right
okay so
okay so the the this is
um all right so another
the case where the association is on the
outside should work like that but i
don't even think that ever works
do you mean this this would be an
association so yes yeah exactly that's
an association and
maybe the inner ones are lists just to
make it a little bit easier for it
but i don't think that usage exists but
it could be wrong
well i'm and i'm not convinced that it
should because i think it
ropes us into a direction we don't want
to go
all right i don't think it's the most
important thing but okay so what what do
we need to figure out next and
actually i'm gonna switch to a different
computer in the hopes that i can
actually get back
into a more appropriate form here i'll
be right back guys
so i i don't think the external head
here plays
any particular role
right right but if it weren't right in
general
it doesn't but if it were an association
you could imagine it doing something
like what we wrote down below with hash
b and hash a
right so like if there was an
association with um
a goes to list one two and b goes to
list a b
oh i see what you mean no yes i see what
i mean so
this is selecting which of these
arguments you i see
right i mean it's unclear if that's what
you want but it's it's it's behavior i
mean
i think that would be the consistent
behavior um
if it did support giving it associations
like that
right
yeah i think you're right there might be
weird ambiguities though if
well i was thinking there might be weird
ambiguities if you had deeper
structures of associations but i have to
think about it so i think
with respect to map thread we have
discussed
three independent generalizations ones
one is is negative threading the other
one
is automatic replication and the third
one is having
different heads
right so you can have a list of f's say
i'm saying i'm by different heads
meaning
you have a list of fs or a list
of f's and g's and you're allowing
to descend into both f and g
i'm just expanding on what you mean by
that third kind of
generalization yes yes i mean that
that for example here we are trained at
the level two
but we are forcing that both
heads are are lists we could have list
and list and then
g and g and it could still be possible
to thread
so as long as as the heads are
consistent per level
should be threadable
and that's where allowed heads might
play a role
this is a random question but i mean
is there any particular reason why these
functions like map thread and i think
transpose as well
care about um key ordering i like care
that the keys are in the
right order
well just because i mean
the implementation we have is of
ordered associations i mean it was a
decision to make and so
lots of functions care that keys are in
the same order
right they're not the same kids but i
mean like you can imagine i mean right
there is ambi there's a little bit of
ambiguity
and like if i give you them in different
orders what order do they come back in
and the resulting association
but 99 of the time you don't really care
um
yeah right i i'm just saying
map thread is not unique i mean like
transpose cares
lots lots of people implemented these as
ordered objects
i mean perhaps we shouldn't have but we
did
so right they they are ordered objects
right i'm just saying that there are a
lot of functions like transposer map
thread which
probably could ignore them could ignore
the ordering
but don't right because there are
functions like you know lookup of course
ignores the ordering and
i mean actually that doesn't really
matter for a while we had these things
without ordering and it was unbelievably
confusing
people thought it was a bug every time
they got back they
because they were using the association
to store a piece of data
and they got back something was in
different order and they were totally
confused so the case that was most
confusing
was the pure no op case where they just
typed in an association the association
came back
and had been reordered
no but you don't want to you don't want
to know right that you definitely don't
want to do i mean associations are
ordered but you'd want to do something
like
use the ordering from the first
association
i see what you're saying why not right
like show i mean so what is the case
that you're talking about
you're saying that it refuses to work if
the map thread refuses to work if the
ordering is different is that correct
and yeah lots of functions you know
that's probably wrong
i mean arguably we could even have an
option that determines
whether it should allow the possibility
of having reordered associations
because you might for safety want to
make sure that they are all in the same
order
but i it seems to me that it should
allow reordering
is there's also one step further sorry
sorry i i i just was going to ask
whether there is a function that can
impose the order of one association on
another
so so that you do it first that's a good
question
would he take a second association
no but it'll be key taken and keys yeah
i know that but that but that's a good
idea that there's
some kind of conforming i mean there is
a notion for machine learning of
conforming one way to another
so sorry i just checked so it looks like
key union
um reorders the associations to all have
the same uh key orders
it's a it's actually the second example
yeah
so so and this actually key union also
has the extension i was going to mention
which is one step further is also that
if the keys don't align at all
you add missings which which key union
does
yeah that's a good idea all right let's
um i i hopefully i'm now able to
actually run
things again so i could share um
i had uh you know unfortunately it would
be nice if it was the case that the
the thing that caused that basically
took over my computer had discovered
something interesting it hadn't
it was just hundreds of rogue kernels
um okay so
okay so the proposed extension of map
thread we basically believe in
i mean do we want to go over more
details of this and we
the the concept of threaded did we have
another concept that we were also
pushing
for um or these were our concepts
implicit threading explicit threading
that that's what you are now calling
generalized map thread right
um yes yes
okay so let's go through i i mean
the generalized map third i think is uh
is a subset of that i think
so i'm i'm not calling i'm not proposing
a different function i'm proposing to
extend
my threat to take negative levels yeah i
understand okay so that's
that's this case of explicit version
then what is this constant array
replicates levels of an array
not quite sure what that what's
array replicate here and then
then there's the headdress form of array
reduce
right which is can we try to remember
what that is about
what that is about
do you mean what array reduce or no the
headdress form of array reduce
so level applied right
so what that's doing is it's saying on
this
array apply f at level
what is this doing
so i guess that's equivalent to array
reduce f comma ray comma two
i assume but i'm now forgetting how
array reduced works
let me remind myself how array reduce
works
um go ahead i i wrote some tentative
examples for array reviews because i was
also trying to
get a better feeling
i actually have to go so bye bye
ah yes i remember now so so i think the
way i understand now i re-reduce is that
it's a combination of first flattening
and then mapping
okay so array reduce is the concept
of for example uh presumably you have
this example immediately here right
are you sure you don't want to give this
with a symbolic matrix this assumes
people can do arithmetic very easily
so these are examples from a tien um
okay well but so so this particular
thing
every row of a matrix
why is that reduced at level two
this is that the surviving level or what
reduces dimension n of array by applying
f
i don't understand why does it do that
why does that mean
yes so the lev you name here the level
that disappears the level that is being
so here we have a three by five array
and so what the level two
is um oh wait a minute wait wait my
mouse is jumping around on the screen
no by god's sake
um
okay hold on
ah let's see we are in
uh where were we functional programming
array processing
i guess sw notes too okay now you're
going to explain why this makes sense
why array reduce so i i was saying that
the number two is uh referring to the
dimension that is going to disappear so
we are taking the mean
of vectors of length five which are in
the second dimension
so it's a different way of looking wait
a minute why are they in
okay hold on hold on this thing here
is this thing
i see i was confused this is really
confusing this should not be used as the
example
we should not have this be a matrix like
that that's really confusing
you understand because it's it's the
second
here it's obviously the second index
right here that is not obviously the
second index
at least not to me do you understand
what i'm saying
i i understand what you're saying yes
yeah
i also think the example is wrong
because i think we should we should be
doing this example here
where we can explicitly see what it's
doing there right
we don't want to use mean where you have
to compute it in your head
right you understand what i'm saying
yeah yeah
i mean so can you change that example
yeah and you're complaining at the right
at the wrong person i mean we can change
this but right now i understand i
understand it so it's okay
it's okay it's all right okay let's
change it because that's a
that's not an understandable example um
okay okay so again let's loop back
to uh what we're trying to figure out so
to me okay we had the headdress form of
array reduce that was the thing
we were talking about here apply f at a
particular
level right
and that was that's a different thing
from all the threading business because
threading is a multi-array story
right yes
here we have flattening too so the the
important thing in array reduce is that
there is this combination of flattening
and mapping
okay but it's a single array operation
yes okay so can we look at level applied
please
because that would be that's a headdress
for you know
f so level applied f comma 2
would be the equivalent of a ray reduce
f onto this thing so the idea would be
that this here
would say apply f
at level two in this thing here
now what's the difference between that
and apply
i'm now very confused what is the
difference between map
f at level two
onto that thing i would say that if we
want a
[Music]
an operative form of afraid radius we
could implement it in a row reduce
itself because
i was just going to ask is there a two
argument form of array reduce
and why do we need a new
i never think so yeah
okay fine so that's a that's then a
headdress
okay so that's a although i do like the
idea of kind of a
a you know apply it to the columns i
mean so this would be
you know the whole point would be to be
able to have code that says something
like
level applied mean comma two of a tense
of an array
would that be would that be right that
would mean apply to the columns
well it's it's not exactly apply
right but but apart from that if you
evaluate array reduce
f we have it in the example you wrote
above
it's applied to the actual rows
so i'm not sure it's the same notation
we need
okay but but what what we were trying to
deal with here
is okay what is the minimal way to take
a matrix and apply an operation to its
columns
is it array reduced comma one
i think so and why is it comma one again
aren't columns at level two aren't
columns the index at level two
this is referring to the
um to the dimension it's going to make
disappear
not so it's it's
it's just a different convention
okay but that to me is you know
the thing that i think i want often is
i've got this array or data set for
example let's take a data set
and i want to you know at a certain
level
and that could be a named level and
we'll come to that in a minute
this could be
i want to do this operation on this
level
does that make sense i believe it makes
sense
so i'm taking every piece
at that level and i am doing this
operation on it
and replacing that level by the thing
that
is that does that make sense or does
that not make sense because every deeper
level is then contracted out
i think it makes sense because the key
idea are re-reduced is that before you
map
you actually transpose that level you
are interested to the bottom
so it's clean and then
but but so let's imagine that i have a
rank three tensor
okay so i've got array a
let's say two three four okay
now i want to what does it mean
to uh apply f
what would level applied okay so let's
let's imagine we had level applied
f comma two of that array what would
that mean
what would that do
right well i mean it's not apply in the
sense of
apply bracket bracket right fine but
just tell me what you think this should
do i mean
what's the natural thing for this to do
does it does it makes sense
or does it not make sense because once
you put the f around it it's no longer
an array
at deeper levels it does so
so array reduce can do this so let's try
a reduce of this array
um so f f comma this array
and then actually two try that
so now do dimensions of this
right so you see how it ate the second
level
yes yes
but let me ask another just question i
mean in terms of displaying things like
this is there a more reasonable way to
display these things i mean
something like table form has a way to
do this
if i'm not mistaken yes though
not everybody can read these things no
i think it's pretty hopeless okay what
would okay in mod
in the modern world given that we have
interactive
ability to display things what should we
use
to display high rank tensors is it
basically data set
is data set the appropriate i mean let's
take a look at what the data set display
mechanism would do for this
it could be so matrix form helps a bit
more because it has a parenthesis
so it's it's able to
to orient yourself a bit right but these
are just matrices right
that's not going to make a huge
difference i mean
what i would do is i would replace the a
in array with subscript of a comma pound
pound
today's point was matrix matrix form
works for things that are not matrices
and
it uses nested parentheses to indicate
that and it's
it's i don't understand what this did
what the heck did this do
what why why how why am i not seeing a
rank three object here
because it's putting everything together
so so the lines have different meanings
so
try try matrix why doesn't it why
doesn't at least have heavier lines
between the ones that aren't
form i think it's the clearest we have
okay
matrix form works for deeper yes
okay yeah so at least here you have do
you see clearly that you have a matrix
of vectors
isn't it a vector of matrix oh yes
matrix of
of vectors so you go and you go it's
like mod
two you go matrix matrix matrix and you
do end up with something that is not a
matrix
so what did this do this made okay this
isn't bad
a matrix of matrices this is what
dataset should use
you know for its display except without
parentheses right
um in some way and i don't know exactly
probably if if we made each of these
things if we framed these things what
would happen if we
is there a way of putting frames in
um yes yes and actually that's
interesting that's what i do
in exact for example i put horizontal
bars too to distinguish a matrix
which is three by one from a vector
okay oh wait wait wait so
hold on so i mean can i actually write
the code to do this what would i do to
make
put a framed at every level here is that
is that am i basically saying
um map all
of framed onto this well that'll
go into the f's too right
that's there are no f's there are a's
here but okay let me make this simpler
let me just do this
oh god what the heck is that so so yes
so remove the all
a map framed at level two sorry
at level two at least two yeah
what did that do no i want to want a map
at level two and level three i think
no i think we need a combination of
framed and matrix form so we need to
put matrix form in inside frame
right easton is complaining on our live
stream that our functions like
map thread and so on to do more we we
are making them do much more
the problem is to keep them so that they
are somewhat understandable so we don't
have to spend half an hour
understanding what they actually do um
but so basically what you're saying is
that
array reduce is a single array thing
which is doing something unachievable by
map thread correct
or is a ray reduce a one argument form
of map thread basically
they are different because a ray reduce
contains flatten inside
and flatten can do lots of things that
map thread cannot
so is there a generalization of map
thread that also does flattening
so so there are four fundamental
operations on tensors which are
separated outer products transpositions
contractions flattenings
okay and so these are the four
independent fundamental ones
and so array reduce is a is some sort of
derivative
and that's why it has this final i mean
it has a couple of transposes inside of
it
but what is platinum in in
in the world of tensors in general
relativity what is flatten
does it exist it's a bit like combining
indices like when you say
i have a decomposition of two spaces and
i'm going to do a two plus two this
composition
so you are going back from the two plus
two to the four
right okay fair enough okay
so all right so it seems to me
okay so an operative form of array
reduce
seems to make sense to me i wish it
wasn't
named quite that way and you're telling
me that my level applied
thing are you telling me well i don't
know what your level applied
thing wants to do i think the use case
that i'm most interested in
is the endless array of of you know
uh do an operation on a column
the endless different version
[Music]
whereby do an operation on the column
you mean
f of the list formed
by yeah yeah and then it depends a lot
on what that returns whether it returns
a list or whether it returns a
a single object or whatever
right maybe we could come to a different
question um
which is this question of named levels
okay because
because that's something we i mean
within
data set for example okay
right now levels are always
just you know positionally indicated
it would be very convenient for dataset
and for many many other things
if levels could be named
am i making sense
yep okay so what is the analog
for just as uh you know an association
is to a list
as a blah is to a nested list
right so one can imagine some kind of
thing that's called um
i don't know what nest i don't know what
it would be called
but an association to remind ourselves
is something where we have taken
you know okay so what would it roughly
look like what we want to do
is we want to say um in this matrix
abcd we are
okay let's just let's just imagine that
it was called level named
of that comma xy
okay there was a wrapper a level named
wrapper
okay and that then operations that
normally specify a level now if we said
go
down to so it might have the same
relationship like if i say
two here that does extract the c
so in other words there might still be a
numbered level
that corresponds even though we've said
for convenience there's naming just like
the keys in the association
for convenience give naming but there is
still a raw level
here am i making sense
yep okay so the question is what would
level named
be what would it um
um uh
you know how would that work so level
names
would be able to take if you if you said
data set of level name then what would
happen is
that the data set when you let's take a
random where's the random data set we've
got
example data um
data set the planet data set
what is it called is it called planets
planets but united list
it's list dataset common clients
okay so
let's imagine that we could name these
levels
so this thing in you know so there's a
there's a level here this is one level
that has that that set of keys this is
another level that has this set of keys
right
yes and then we have two more right so
these are four
okay right but so imagine that this was
so if i were to do a normal on this will
be a big complicated mess
um okay but but then
if this was a a level named object
see one issue is you want a kind of a
global level named
you you don't want to spray i mean okay
so the other issue we know we have
okay is is the spraying of the fact that
we have
row oriented storage we don't have we
don't have a way to share
the keys across similar rows
am i making sense
yeah right so we we know that we also
want
and i guess we're doing this for data
set the a version of data set in which
the keys are shared right
is that correct
i'm not sure why would we want to share
oh yes yes and i understand what you
mean yes
right can you explain to me because i'm
not sure what he means
yes so so the idea is that when you have
a data set with columns
with headers the keys are replicated
in all rows so we want a way of
having we want to save the storage
associated with
and other things associated with the
fact that we're repeating mass radius
moons
um
now i don't know whether that's a
whether that is top level accessible to
people or whether that just magically
happens i mean it's kind of like
it's kind of an analog of a packed array
you know
for data set if i'm not mistaken right
and i think that's something that's
being worked on right jose
um yes yes and and i know that there is
uh the
the image processing team is
particularly interested in this yeah
okay but are they working on it actively
they have
their own i think they call it data
frame object
internally okay which does this which is
what we can use
for data set right right
okay okay well fine but but then then
that object
so so this thing here level named
we could imagine having something where
we have a syntax where at every level
every time we say abcd
right we're annotating right just like
we could re-annotate the keys here we
could say list
you know x goes to a y goes to b
right we're we're repeating those keys
see what i'm saying we could imagine a
similar
repeated keys version of
named levels
so i'm saying we're instead we're
basically what's happening is
look here's how you do it you would put
a headdress
around okay so let's say we we say okay
this is how we do it we'd say named
well named level
uh list
level x
of named level
list comma y a b
named level
list comma y cd
right that would be the explicit form
just like
the explicit form of repeating keys in
the association
i see
right so in principle we could do this
even now
we could put a headdress form of list
where that could be ingested by
data set just the same way that
list and association are ingested by
data set
so what i'm saying so then here this
will be a convenience
labeling just like in associations keys
or convenience labeling
but there's still a raw uh part number
that's left there
right in this particular case with this
way of doing it
we would have to do nothing more because
so long as you weren't doing head
operations so to speak
this this would just work
right in other words the the the old
level numbers the old integer level
numbers would still work
but now all we have to do is to have
something which does if you say level y
it has to find level y
this assumes you have been careful to
name the same level
consistently i know i know it's just
like
in a data set right if you called if i
didn't have this
if i had this with a z goes to c and i
made that into a data set
it would no longer align if you
understand what i'm saying
yes but i i'm i guess i'm complaining
about the name by name by calling it
named level
it's a bad name it's a bad name if
you've got a better name suggest it
i'm i'm i'm just um uh
right i mean i'm i'm just saying
this is the right this is the explicit
form
this is the implicit internal form i
mean in a
which you might want to use i don't know
whether you want to use it
this is a form i mean this might turn
into this it might spray
these things in here and it could be the
case that syntactically what would
happen is
okay that this says abcd
okay and i don't know if this is going
to work but let me try it if i do this
and i say control whatever x
control whatever y
it's kind of an elegant but but you see
what i'm saying so something
roughly like that
this reminds me very much of indices in
tensors when we have the array and then
we have a wrapper around it and we say
within this is i j and so i
helps you to go to the first level and j
to the second level
how does that work with tensors explain
so imagine that you have something like
in let's invent something like indexed
well no indexing we have already um
cancelled the tensor yeah invent some
word and then
we put an array in the first level
metrics and the other one yeah and then
because that's level two
we have a list called ij which are the
two indices of this object
and now this object would represent with
the whole matrix as usual perhaps in
matrix form with the
sub indices i j and now for example if
we do a transposition of this
we return something which is j i
but the original matrix is the same it's
just the ji is different
so this is it has been drive pose so if
we transpose the object
we transpose the matrix we move the
indices to remember we have transposed
it
okay so wait a minute this is this is
basically
explicit tensors meets implicit tensors
is that right yes if you want yeah
because an implicit tensor is something
like you know
tij or something is an implicit tensor
right right and the transpose of tij is
tji
right but this is saying so
explain um
so let's imagine that we want to check
that this tensor
is symmetric right
so we transpose it and then we would get
10 sort of ac bd
okay
just to understand what it does yep this
followed by j i but yeah
okay so in other words okay so that
and that's exactly what we would get up
here naturally if we transpose this
it would take the labels would be
carried around
right that's the natural thing to do
here
okay
so but this says
your tensored is pretty much the same as
my level named
is that true
yes yes i think so okay
and but the main okay so what are some
examples of things we can do so
in data set
with our weird query language right what
we're doing with the weird query
language so
you know data set queries for example
right now we're saying data set
and then we do an operation that is the
the
um axis one operation
then the axis two operation and so on
right
so the obvious thing to be doing would
be something where we say
you know we have an association and we
have an axis names
axis name um
and then then we have an operation right
is that right
tally you probably have opinions about
this
if you're talking you're muted
well we seem to have lost totally a
thing
hopefully not a scheduled power cut in
south africa or some other bizarre thing
like that
yeah i don't see him in the meeting
anymore okay
okay well um okay
sandra is pointing out
yes yes i mean sandra is pointing out
that what you could do with tensored
or level named is you could say um
you know map onto map f
onto level named blah blah blah blah
blah
comma x and that would indeed map
at on the x on the level named x
right that's the idea and then with data
set
you would say do this operation so
instead of having to do the weird thing
where you have to say
right now you'd have to say data set all
comma
all comma f you see what i'm saying to
do an operation on level
three right right whereas
what this would be doing is you'd be
saying something more like i mean i
don't know whether you can do this maybe
you can already do this maybe it has
some weird syntax
thing where you can already do that to
do an operation
at level three
so it's making sense there is an
annotation like that but i think the
three means
position not the level position
in the level you have in this case will
be the first level
okay okay so but in any case this
this would mean you know this is again
some kind of level applied
thing of
all right this isn't quite right i mean
this is this is again if we had level
applied
right we could say level applied f x to
data set
which means apply f at level x
although it might be sufficient to just
say apply
f comma x data set that might actually
do it
or at level x for example like this
right well with the with the full form
we wouldn't have
an operator form of apply with two
arguments but but
right right excuse me so it would be
really nice to have
in the data set the four levels named
planets planet properties moons moon
properties
exactly exactly that's the point
do we have anybody here from the image
processing team who knows about this
data frame concept
yes we have sharon from machine learning
do you have a comment on this
nope okay you're wrong i
i i think i do prefer to not make the
same
i mean the same problem that we have
with data set of replicating so if we
can keep the levels
kind of separate at a very high level
in data set i think that would be the
most flexible thing well
what happens if you extract something
okay so the question is
i mean okay so this is named levels
let's say that you have a a named thing
like this for example
right so we have this or we have level
named
you know abcd
xy alright so let's say we've got
this is called ln for example okay
so one thing we might want to do is
extract we would normally say part
number two three
two two one let's say okay but we want
to be also able to say
ln of essentially part
well here's what we would want to do we
want to say extract
from ln okay does this make any sense
you see what i'm about to do
i see what you're going but i wouldn't
do this for general expression so i
would it would be
something in data set so data set knows
about
level names and you can extract from
data sets and extract other data sets
that keep
the level names corresponding to the
thing distracted
why would you not do it for anything
with level named
just support that as a as a construct
that things like extract
could deal with but why not have level i
mean the part of level named if you did
you know part of that two it could give
you level named
of the second part comma y
they could keep that it can keep the
names when it's when it's not down to
the elements
it could keep the names yes
right no i mean that's what i'm
proposing and that's what it would do
naturally
in other words if if we had the concept
of an if
as if sprayed form you understand what
i'm saying
that everything is as if it was this it
isn't in fact this but it's as if it was
this
see what i'm saying so
you know so it's some okay
so now the question would be
in okay
what other operations would do
interesting things with level name so
so transpose of level named
you're saying and i don't completely
understand this would both
transpose the okay what would flatten do
for level named
[Music]
so the names would combine would be
combinations of names
so but you would have a that would be
weird
right because with button you can comply
combine these
levels right so it would have to be the
combined level
so that would be you know in a sense
flatten of level named
would have to be something like
boy what would it be it would be i mean
it would have to say
something like um you know level named
of and then it would be it would be this
with this thing flattened out right then
the second thing would be
some some kind of combined level wrapper
yeah or a list well i don't know whether
it can be a list because it would
already be a list but it could be
it could be possibly exactly
that thing so now the the
there is a single level named list xy
so maybe i missed something but with
transpose why can't we just store a
permutation
instead of transposing both the
both the names and the expression
we probably could from a storage point
of view yes
um
okay but so what about other operations
what what would be um
for example array reduce clearly that
would be a
a prime user of this
type of named level idea
i mean look named levels are obviously a
good idea the question is
what you know can we imagine what would
be involved in in
implementing these and what's the you
know is this the right conceptual way to
think about them
i think i claim that it is so my word
here is
is homogeneity so arrayness arrays
are have consistent heads if you don't
have consistent heads then we are
in the trees world
and so in in a sense here what you have
is a first level of a tree called x and
then
having two children and and we could
have where y
one y two and now we'll have a really an
array because the two heads are
different
but perhaps it still makes sense in some
three approach
um okay but i mean in look
the basic point is for us you know
at the user level an array is a list of
lists for us
right by by putting in this named level
thing
we are making it a more integral object
right i mean right now we don't have a i
mean it would be nice to be able to have
something where you can extract pieces
of it
and they would come with their level
name in other words it's a
it's a way of annotating just like okay
association has been a huge win
because it allows one to basically
annotate
one some um you know
it's it's you know it's much better to
have rather than just the list but
four five five six seven right if we can
say
um you know name
[Music]
you know rank whatever right it's much
it is a an it is a a good way of
annotating data
right so right this similarly
is a way of annotating data it's like in
the planet's data set
what does each level mean and to my mind
you do want to be able to carry that
around
i see what about the level in which the
level
is an association itself so do we have a
some sort of
named association no but i'm saying
you headdress in in this conceptual view
of it
everything has a level name headdress
yes but we're talking about association
we're gonna drop association right
because association is atomic so
well how can we really wrap list okay
this is a conceptual thing right we're
we're introducing a wrapper that would
have to be somehow transparent
i see i see right because otherwise
named list i mean
if you take eigenvalues of this thing
right it's got to work
even though these are somehow named
level lists and i don't know
right so i mean it might be that
implementationally we introduce it first
in something like dataset but i'm saying
i think it's useful as a concept
for okay again let me remind you
that currently when we take this and we
take the normal
you know take this as normal we are
spraying you know masses and radii
for every planet you see what i'm saying
yep
okay so i'm saying take the analog of
that
that it is as if as if you were spraying
it
into each of these heads right now in
practice it might be stored much more
efficiently than that
just as dataset hopefully in the future
will store things much more efficiently
um well um yeah
let me okay so i'll first say
it's not entirely clear to me what the
i mean i guess i sort of understand but
it's not
all clear to me how this would work but
my other comment is going to be right we
introduced pact arrays in what 2002 are
thereabouts
and there are still bugs with you know
things not handling factories
okay this is an implementation issue i
understand
hey let me finish my sentence okay
right so yeah you know
this is uh right this is significantly
more complicated than pacquiao's
so you know you're talking about a
multi-year project
just as long as you're aware of that i
understand
to to put the sin everywhere is a is a
complicated project
yes that's but we should figure out
where we want to go
and then we figure out perhaps first
step is to put it into data set
yeah i think so it would be very nice to
see to say something like map
on the moons for example in the planets
data set without having to worry about
which level it is
exactly right but but so you know
it could be the case that data set
contains
a level name but we don't yet have sort
of naked level names
right okay but but the whole point is
that the the um and i mean data set is a
simpler case because
all of your issues about raggedness
don't occur there
because data set is simply a sound of
lists and associations
that doesn't mean it can't be ragged no
no no no
no no i i mean generalized raggedness
yeah generalized raggedness if in this
expression here i could have written you
know
i mean
let's call it level raggedness or
something you know
or head raggedness that's what i'm
talking about
right i'm talking about something where
you go a b
g of a c d right
right yeah so the dataset case is
simpler because it's only lists and
associations that's clear
right but so what it would take
within dataset
how would you enter a data okay what
would happen when you say normal
of a level named data set
would it lose the labels i think so
probably has to okay so then going into
data set what you would do is you would
say data set
of this thing here and you would say
something like uh you know it's not the
right name but you know level names
arrow x y here
right that's that's how you would set it
up
yep
[Music]
so we're only going allowing
maybe it only makes sense right but
isn't this assuming some level of
rectangularity which
you're certainly not guaranteed in a
data set no that's the whole point
the the ite the whole point is the whole
point the point this is the point about
head raggedness right
data set cannot it's not it's not head
raggedness right
i mean like uh this doesn't care whether
this is cde it doesn't make any
difference that
doesn't care about that it's only naming
think about these level names as being
head decorations
right they're decorations for the heads
on level one decorations for the heads
on level two and so on
right so e is still at level two even
though this is
not restangular yes right it's purely
decorating the heads
or aka the levels in this case because
because it isn't the case that in a data
set you can't do
i suspect the following thing i don't
think i can do
a b and then say x
one y two i don't think that's a valid
data set
is it well it will be considered a role
to things like
i think
what the heck did that do right see
what did that do well it's doing better
than
than i was expecting but
i mean it's a valid stat in the sense
that data set can take lists and
associations
and and okay okay that makes sense that
makes sense and if i if i put another
copy of that association there
okay that seems right okay but there's
no problem with the with the
named levels for this thing right so the
difficult thing is to read back the
the i mean if you had to reconstruct
this the internal structure of the data
set from this output
it wouldn't be easy
right i mean i just right so
i can't claim to have completely thought
this through but
i can tell you from personal experience
right i i click down and i see
some new square of values
i mean you're not seeing it here but
like if you like the planets data set
right
and i'll see a different square in
in them and so i'm not i'm not sure
like nasa named level
or not no it's not a named level it's an
association it's a key in an association
this is a named level so this is this is
planet properties is a named level mass
radius moons that's a named level
right so at this level the the
level up first here is planet properties
okay right so this the label
of this layer is planet properties
okay so venus is at the level of planets
and then we have
massive properties of planet properties
so this
so what we could do here is in this
breadcrumb
we could annotate you know planets
no that's the planets level this is the
planet properties level
right so we would annotate the
breadcrumbs
right and the well okay so so go
right so i guess that that quantity
there
of of its mass is at the
planet subprime it's below planet
properties but
that's of course not going to be
homogeneous because some properties
might be themselves compound
yeah in which case there's different
level look
specifying okay your point is
if the thing has fingers that reach down
into subsequent levels in some parts of
the data set but not others
there might be some things that would
have labels x y
z and other ones that would just have
labels x y
yes that's what i was trying to say and
said it very poorly
okay right i understand the issue so
then the question is if you say
um apply to level x
well we have that issue already with
dataset right we have the issue already
so i'm saying there's a question okay so
there's there's level raggedness
head ragginess is one thing then there's
level raggedness
right then i get and what dataset does
right now
i i don't actually know what what
dataset does right now with
level raggedness
um i need to get going here uh
okay something first to think about for
next time i i don't think the
yeah i don't think it's a problem i mean
the problem already is a map
if you have something rugged and you say
map
at the level three and not everything
has levels right
yeah then it just doesn't do it it no it
maps what it can
it maps on the things that are at level
three it doesn't bother right
about the rest by the way ethan is
complaining about the fact that dataset
doesn't support out-of-core operations
we are working hard on that
um also the fact that query gets too
complicated i agree
we need we need essentially a query
builder we need some kind of
code assistance mechanism around query
and that's again
something that is at least an active
discussion and something we probably
should
should actually somehow we should merge
some version of this meeting with the
code assistance crew
and try and talk about that at some
point
makes sense yeah yeah
okay all right thank you everybody i
should i need to go
and um for those paying attention i'm
actually doing another we're doing
two more live streams today oh my gosh
another at the top of the next
hour i'm doing a q a about business and
innovation
um but uh and we're doing another
design meeting at um
uh well 4 30 eastern time no idea what
it is in other time zones
um and i need some lunch and i'll see
you guys later
thank